ce matin en présence de monsieur main
jours le maire de besançon de ses
collaborateurs et d'une foule nombreuse
la fontaine de la place du 8 septembre
l'ancienne place saint pierre a été mise
en eau cette manifestation marquait la
fin des travaux de la première tranche
des espaces piétonniers de la capitale
de la franche comté
c'est la grand rue la voie de
pénétration la plus ancienne qui a été
choisi pour devenir l' axe piétonnier
pourquoi parce qu'elle est la plus
commerçante la plus riche par sa qualité
architecturale et aussi parce que les
parcs de stationnement sont à 300 m
toutes les conditions se trouvait donc
réunis pour une expérience originale
devant réhabiliter un centre ville que
l'utilisation abusive de l'automobile
risque est de détruire nous avons
réservé des espaces aux piétons car nous
voulions absolument refaire de la ville
le lieu des changes que la ville aurait
dû toujours être et nous avons donc
pensé qu'il fallait pour que les piétons
reviennent à ravir leur donner à nouveau
un espace qui leur soient effectivement
aménagé à l'heure à leur procès alors
pourquoi avoir simplement pris une
partie de la grand bruit n'ont pas la
totalité
tout d'abord parce que au niveau
financier nous étions obligés qu'ils ont
tenus de faire un programme évolutif et
ensuite nous avons pris la partie de la
grande rue qui était la plus fréquentée
par les badauds a besoin sont une partie
de la grande rue qui était la plus
animée
au niveau des commerces est également
une partie de la grande rue qui nous
permettait avec la place pasteur à la
place du x est corps de prévoir une
animation correct il a fallu pour cela
d'importants travaux et donc des crédits
6 millions 200 mille francs au total
dont 2 millions fournis par l'état
l'aménagement de la place pasteur ayant
coûté 430000 font les résultats il
paraît difficile de ne pas les apprécie
sur une surface qui est environ de 6
mille huit cents mètres carrés au total
comprenant la grande rue et les la place
saint pierre et la place pasteur
nous avons tout d'abord rechercher ce
qui était je crois essentiel avec mon
confrère lacroix et inde approcher le
plus possible les façades qui sont très
architecturé et dont les couleurs sont
tout à fait exceptionnelles pour la
région
cette pierre bleue et jaune qui nous
environne nous avons essayé donc de la
retrouver au sol et c'est hélas notre
première approche du problème donc un
problème de revêtement et de couleurs de
ce revêtement
alors nous avons visité plusieurs
carrières nous avons réussi donc à
obtenir avec la pierre de buxy et une
pierre beige du jura d'obtenir donc
cette liaison avec les façades pour la
place saint-pierre qui représente un
ensemble très ordonnance et nous avons
préféré choisir un mouvement de sol
qu'ils soient le plus plat possible
alors que l'as pasteur nous avons
cherché au contraire une dominante plus
surélevé sorte de podiums sur lesquels
nous avons pensé que les gens pouvaient
se réunir se retrouver et l'on s'y
retrouve effectivement tout au long du
jour et de la soirée surtout lorsqu'il
fait beau les jeunes d'abord qui
apprécient de plus en plus les gradins
qui monte l'eau qui descend mais tous
les piétons aussi qui flânent alentours
ou qui passent sans craindre les
accidents
on
le premier bilan qu'on peut faire les
comptages qui avait été fait avant
l'aménagement un espace piétonnier nous
montrait que sur cette partie de la
grande rue il y avait 500 piétons alors
aux heures de pointe 1 samedi après midi
nous avons refait des comptages au mois
de mars de cette année après les
aménagements et nous avons décompté
11300 piétons donc doublement du nombre
de piétons et diminution pour 50 % de la
pollution atmosphérique
[Musique]